which of the following can represent a
vector so a vector is something that has
both a magnitude and a direction so
let's see which of these could represent
something that has a magnitude and a
direction so the first choice right over
here is the number 5 well 5 could
represent a magnitude you could say
essentially how large something is but
it that's all the information has it
doesn't say 5 in a certain direction so
this one by itself would not be a or it
couldn't represent a vector you need you
need to specify a direction as well the
angle measure 5 degrees well the angle
measure 5 degrees could represent a
direction if you say it's 5 degrees
let's say that's the positive x-axis
that's the positive y-axis if you said
it's 5 degrees relative to the positive
x-axis so if you said something like
this so if you had 5 degrees right over
there that wouldn't be specifying a
direction but it's not giving us a
magnitude it's not saying how far in
that direction or how large in that
direction so an angle measure of 5
degrees you're giving us a direction but
no magnitude so let's just cross these
out the point 5 comma 5 now this is
interesting if if we say that the point
is the end point of a vector that
started that starts at the origin so
let's draw that out so if that's the
positive x-axis positive y-axis if this
is see 1 2 3 4 5 in the horizontal
direction 1 2 3 4 5 in the positive
vertical direction then the point 5
comma 5 is going to be is going to be
right over there and so if you said that
this represents the essentially the head
of a vector that whose tail is at the
origin so the vector would look
something like this
now you're giving both a magnitude and a
direction what's the magnitude what's
the distance between the origin and this
point right over here which you could
solve using the Pythagorean theorem and
the direction is this this the direction
that that I've just drawn the vector
it's this general it's that general
direction so this is best or this could
specify a magnitude and a direction so
this could represent a vector the
outcome of five plus five well obviously
that's just ten that's just a number and
for the same reason this first choice if
I just have a number that could be a
magnitude but we don't have a direction
as well so this could not represent and
that one could not represent a vector